WOMEN WANT AND IT STARRED MEL
GIBSON.
ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW.
>> THE PERFECT MAN, A COLD
STATUE.
AND THE CASTING COUCH CULTURE OF
WEINSTEIN AND OTHERS.
LAST NIGHT'S SHOW, THE
CONTRIBUTOR, SHE LIVES OUT THIS.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHY.
TOMI.
I'M WATCHING IT UNTIL HOMELAND
CAME ON.
I'M SITTING THERE THINKING,
NOBODY CAN CAN TOLERATE THIS.
I NEW IT WOULD BE A DISASTER
RATINGS WISE.
>> IT WAS PERFECT.
AN ACTOR IS PAID A RIDICULOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO PRETEND
SOMETHING THEY'RE NOT.
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS PRETEND
TO BE HUMANITARIANS AND THEY'RE
OVERPAID HYPOCRITES.
THEY'RE NOT FUNNY.
THEY TRIED TO BE FUNNY AND STILL
NOT FUNNY.
>> HOW IS IT THE CROWD THAT
JUST A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
LITERALLY GIVES THE LOUDEST
APPLAUSE TO A GUY THAT -- THAT
DRUGGED A 13-YEAR-OLD GIRL AND
REPEATEDLY RAPED HER.
HOW DID THAT GUY GET THE BIGGEST
APPLAUSE AND HOW DO WE BELIEVE
THEM?
I THINK THEY'RE PHONIES.
>> THERE'S NOTHING MORE PHONY
THAN THE ME TOO AND TIMES UP
MOVEMENT.
IT SHOULD BE HASH TAG WE ALL NEW
AND WE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING UNTIL
IT WAS TRENDY.
THOSE THAT ARE INTERVIEWING
PEOPLE AND THOSE THAT ARE
FRIENDS WITH PEOPLE LIKE
WEINSTEIN, THEY KNEW AND HAD A
GOOD IDEA AND SAID NOTHING.
THEY ALLOWED IT TO CONTINUE AND
NOW THEY WEAR A PIN AND MAKE
JOKES ABOUT IT.
THEY THINK THEY'RE DOING THE
COUNTRY GOOD AND WOMEN GOOD, AND
THEY THINK THEY'RE STARTING A
MOVEMENT.
HYPOCRITING
HYPOCRITIN
HYPOCRITEN
HYPOCRITES
HYPOCRITE
HYPOCRITES.
>> WHEN YOU PULL UP WHAT DID
YOU SEE IN ARMED COPS AND SWAT
TEAMS.
IF WE'RE GOING TO SECURE THE
PERIMETER OF THE OSCARS CAN'T WE
DO THAT IN AMERICA'S SCHOOLS?
>> I THINK WHAT IS GREAT ABOUT
THE SECOND AMENDMENT, IT
PROTECTS THOSE OF US WHO CAN'T
AFFORD ARMED SECURITY.
I THOUGHT MAYBE THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE ARMED SECURITY GUARDS,
MAYBE THAT WOULD GIVE THEM